when people think about hunger strikes
you know they think about Gandhi who was
striking on behalf of the untouchables
nelson mandela who was striking for
better prison conditions on Robben
Island where does your hunger strike
match up in the pantheon of hunger
strikes symbolically show that the
postal service is being starved in the
way that we're being starved 15 million
dollars a day is what the postal service
is being starved from because Congress
is not acting since 2006 2011 total mail
volume is down 21% there have been net
losses of twenty twenty billion dollars
and about a hundred and forty thousand
employees have gone isn't this what has
to happen I mean there's less mail being
delivered there's got to be fewer people
delivering the mail well the problem is
not the bug the mail volume and problem
is not the Internet the problem is not
even a private competition the problem
is a pre-funding mandate that Congress
imposed on 2000-2006 let the Postal
Service pre-fund retiree health benefits
seventy-five years in advance labor is
eighty percent of postal service costs
at UPS it's fifty three percent at FedEx
it's thirty two percent r is the Postal
Service paying too much in labor costs
they are not as a matter of fact you're
going to get a lot of various numbers
out there the point that we want to make
to the American public is that whether
you're looking at labor costs six day
delivery or any other factor they are
all irrelevant compared to the
pre-funding mandate how do you change a
business model I mean you have however
else you want to talk about it you've
got declining volume yeah so how do you
how do you change a structure to
accommodate that there's okay as far as
saturday delivery goes the Postal
Service needs to continue to deliver on
saturday because if they don't private
competition will jump in and that will
diminish its volume further what you do
is you look for bills in Congress that
promote marketing flexibility for the
Postal Service that give it a chance to
try some new ideas maybe set up a
National Savings Bank
a system where the letter carriers and
the different different delivery
personnel could check on elderly people
the the postal service could be involved
with Homeland Security what's the first
thing that you're going to eat when you
when you end the hunger strike probably
for me a Cobb salad justice justice soup
ready any particular kind of like a
broth or a gumbo uh whatever's on sale
an apple thank you again guys thanks
very much
you